[Musik]
ich habe in dem Block hier tatsächlich
bisher kein einziges Wort gesagt und das
vielleicht auch besser so was ich
niemand dafür juckt was ich Dummkopf zu
erzählen habe
[Musik]
fertig
und ihr fragt euch jetzt wahrscheinlich
auch gerade Mensch Luca warum blockst du
denn heute
ich habe ein Date
mit einem Mädel
und ich wollte die Kamera mitnehmen weil
ich bin ein bisschen aufgeregt kommt
aber jetzt gleich rum
[Musik]
da ist so gespannt ich sehe die jetzt
gerade gleich zum ersten Mal in Reallife
[Musik]
[Applaus]
menschlich gesehen ziemlich abstoßend
freust dich auf unser Date
chillig
oh
nein damals natürlich nicht nur hier
heute morgen bei mir vorbei gekommen
weil wir bei unserer Date haben wo gehen
wir hin
ja wir sind doch schon hier tatsächlich
auf Grund ist wegen
das ist ein Wortspiel aus wiegen und
General und ähm bezieht sich darauf dass
der komplette ja nur veganisch dann in
Ernährung ne
und dann nehmen wir teilen hat uns
gefragt ob wir das ganze mit denen
bestreiten wollen sich nämlich zur
Aufgabe gemacht im Rahmen des wir
genuary zu zeigen wie einfach es ist mit
Lieferando vegan zu essen und wie viel
Spaß wir gehen wir very macht
sandra war schon Einkaufen man kann sich
aber auch über Baguette hier vegane
Lebensmittel erstellen und dafür braucht
ihr tatsächlich mal die App zu wechseln
der neuerdings ist auch möglich direkt
über die Lieferando App vegane
Lebensmittel Baguette zu bestellen Leute
vegane Map veganes oder vegan mit
gefunden
ihr könnt sie ja einmal komm mal schön
die ist du ja so gerne dann äh habe ich
total vergessen dass Frischkäse ja Milch
drin hat hör auf mich so nah zu filmen
dann habe ich Frischkäse gekauft und
Butter gibt's auch ein vegan und ich
musste tatsächlich 15 Minuten beim Brot
nachstöbern welches vegan ist weil ganz
viele Brotsorten haben Milch enthalten
deswegen das ist ein Brot
aber ich mache jetzt so eine coole
salatische Aufnahme wie wir uns das Brot
belegen
no joke Frühstück bei Sandra ist es halt
so dass du exakte Ersatzprodukte hast
fürs Bett und sowas alles du ist ja
eigentlich sonst nur glaube ich ja zum
Frühstück
auch noch so Rührei oder Spiegeleier
esse ich weiß nicht gibt's gar keine
vegane alternative kurze Anmerkungen aus
der Redaktion ihr seht ihr bereits neben
mir schon eingeblendet es gibt
tatsächlich eine vegane Alternative für
Spiegeleier auch für Rühreier etc man
kann das ganz einfach selber machen mit
Kürbispüree Rapsöl Hefeflocken etc
google einfach mal alles krank auf jeden
Fall noch unser Frühstück auf ähm das
haben wir bisher auf jeden Fall gut
gemeistert finde ich
Orangensaft ist vegan ne
ja schön vegan stark
wer ist jetzt auf
und dann wir machen coolen Übergang mit
dem Toast
zwei Stunden später
waschwäsche
ja da jetzt rechts
jetzt links doch links man muss Dusche
so gegen die Felsen klopfen
hinten in der Dusche
aber ohne Waschmittel geht das doch
nicht ja
eine Stunde ist vergangen
[Applaus]
die hat die Decke nicht mal aufmachen
müssen
Alter auf jeden Fall ist eine Stunde
vergangen jetzt wieder wir haben beide
tatsächlich wieder Hunger bekommen weil
wir einfach verfressen Idioten sind es
ist doch einfach so schönes Wetter
draußen ne wir hängen hier drin
ist allerdings auf jeden Fall bei
Lieferando etwas veganes zu essen wie
heute für unsere 24 Stunden vegan wir
versuchen ja und selber die Challenge zu
stellen dass die ganzen
durchzuziehen ob wir das schaffen werden
weil sie nicht sonder wollte auch
eigentlich auch frei sein in diesem Jahr
aber guck mal was hier bei der rechten
liegt wie lange hast du es bisher
geschafft
hast du unten nach 0 Uhr geschafft wir
bestellen jetzt allerdings einen
leckeren Burger bei burgermee nimmt
tatsächlich am Beginn rary auch teil und
da gibt es aktuell einen regen und zwar
das vegane Menü da genießt man nämlich
einen wiegen choice einen wiegen choice
Crunch und einen wiegen Salat mit einem
Dressing
in 15 Minuten ist das da wir haben
unsere Serie einfach 9 Minuten 17
geschaut wegen so einer neuen Netflix
Serie die ist bisher ganz geil ne und
das Essen kann einfach an
ja hier ist Salat und wir haben zweimal
Burger hier sind die beiden Burger
wir haben vier
hast du das Menü zweimal bestellt
beinhaltet zwei Burger und einen Salat
Dojo ich habe noch nie einen Salat so
schön geliefert bekommen
gar keinen Unterschied mehr
[Musik]
und da ist mittlerweile schon halb neun
ist würden wir uns jetzt tatsächlich
auch unser Abendessen bestellen ey es
tut mir leid dieser Vlog wenn ihr jetzt
noch dran seid es ist wirklich einfach
ein es ist eine Frechheit
uns hier beim beim Chillen zuzugucken
was wollten ja ganz viele mal sehen ja
macht Spaß
wir bestellen jetzt auf jeden Fall was
bei wie heißt der Laden noch mal wir
bestellen jetzt auf jeden Fall bei Dean
and David weil Luca guckt mich nicht so
an weil die auch Teil der veganyuary
kann das nicht aussprechen gerade sagen
wollte aber nicht aussprechen konnte
weil sie blöd ist ist dass wir jetzt bei
dir und David unser Abendessen bestellen
die nämlich auch am Beginner really Teil
im Rahmen dieser ganzen Lieferando
Aktion erhält man dann auch noch 1 € auf
Bolz von daher können wir uns jetzt was
nur wenige Minuten später das Abendessen
kann man meine Damen und Herren wir
haben bereits gesagt bei den David
bestellt ich mir so eine Salat sich auch
eine salute dazu wir beide noch mal
schicken
übrigens genommen
darauf wie es schmeckt ist Sommer
ich bestelle tatsächlich relativ häufig
bei Ihnen und David und auch eigentlich
immer vegan Eier nehme ich die sind
nicht vegan auf die Gesundheit hier mit
unserem Kurkuma irgendwas Musik
man schmeckt sehr gut wir haben heute
gemeinsam mit Lieferando uns ein paar
vegane Restaurants hier bei uns aus der
Ecke angeschaut und da auch bestellt wir
haben Lebensmittel eingekauft im
Supermarkt haben uns ja veganes
Frühstück gemacht und generell einfach
so einen kompletten Schultag miteinander
verbracht ne
toll was toll du hast schon gesagt was
hat dir am besten geschmeckt heute
ich glaube tatsächlich der Burger
meine Lieferando Jacke angezogen die ich
aber meiner letzten Kooperation mit
Lieferando vielleicht abgezogen habe
danke dafür nochmal allerdings könnt ihr
auch ganz simpel am Beginn rarity
teilnehmen indem ihr einfach vegane
Dinge esst
es ist wirklich sehr simpel das ist uns
heute wieder aufgefallen vor allem weil
es mittlerweile so viele Ersatzprodukte
gibt dir euch entweder bei geht hier in
Form von Lebensmittel bestellen können
oder wenn die Lieferando in Form von
direkt fertigen perfekten Essen
innerhalb von Minuten
später hier ja das checke ich immer noch
nicht wie die das hingekriegt haben wenn
nicht der heutige etwas chilligere Block
allerdings gefallen hat dann das Geld
einen Daumen hoch unter dem Video hier
da abonniert meinen Kanal und klickt auf
die Glocke weitere Videos nicht zu
verpassen alle weiteren Informationen zu
Lieferando findet ihr unten in der
Videobeschreibung allerdings
danke schön
[Musik]